we're going to begin this hour with new
reporting on the collapse of hospitals
serving some of America's most
vulnerable patients in the latest part
of our CBS News investigation we're
digging into the role of private Equity
investors in hospitals so we followed
the money that's what they say you
always need to do follow the money to
San Antonio where next week the
community will be left without a crucial
health care provider how is that
possible our chief medical correspondent
John lapuc is here with more good
morning to you John good morning Gail
our investigation led us to San
Antonio's Texas Vista Medical Center
which until 12 days ago was the place
respiratory therapist Jessica Carrasco
had worked for eight years
if you were to Walk The Halls right now
not to sound dramatic but it feels like
somebody's dying what do you mean you're
walking through somewhere that used to
have so much life and it feels like
someone's taking their last breaths for
nearly 40 years Texas Vista Medical
Center has been the Primary Health Care
option for San Antonio's majority
Hispanic South Side when it shuts down
on Monday this part of town will have
only one full-service Hospital 110 beds
for about half a million people I feel
like I need to apologize to the patient
Jessica Carrasco was one of more than
800 employees told in March she would be
out of a job when the hospital announced
it was planning to close its doors the
nearest hospital is between 12 to 15
minutes away and if you're having a
stroke or a heart attack time is of the
essence in 2017 a private equity-backed
firm called Steward Health Care purchase
Texas Vista while Steward would operate
the hospital the land and building were
sold to another entity called medical
properties trust which has brought up
the real estate of nearly 200 U.S
hospitals often in low-income areas they
recognize an opportunity and that was
Private Equity looking to sell Hospital
systems investment analyst Rob Simone
has advised clients to bet against the
publicly traded company but told us he
doesn't trade on the company himself
medical properties trust does not employ
any of the doctors or the EMS Personnel
what they do is they provide cash
Capital to the folks that run the
hospital
that's it and they get back a check for
rent on its website medical properties
trust says this allows cash starved
hospitals to unlock the value of their
real estate assets to pay for
improvements they might say you know
we're giving money so that the hospital
can actually invest that they would but
many of the hospitals are struggling and
failing a yes news investigation found a
pattern of supply shortages at 14
hospitals where medical properties trust
owns the real estate in Massachusetts at
least 16 vendors weren't paid on time
including a dialysis company that
provided life-saving services to five
hospitals and by earlier this year
Steward Healthcare had missed more than
650 thousand dollars in payments to at
least a dozen different vendors serving
Texas Vista coordinators were having to
phone a friend to let us borrow you know
a cup of sugar for example we provide
patients with a non-invasive ventilation
device a breathing mask right and if I
don't have the hose to connect from the
machine to the mask
I can't do anything for them on March
1st the cash crunch exploded into public
view when Stewart announced it intended
to shut Texas Vista in 60 days would
something like this do you think happen
in a more affluent Community now
councilwoman Adriana Rocha Garcia
represents the San Antonio residents
most affected by a closure my people my
residents are one minute away from
losing hope Steward the owner points to
its disproportionately free care higher
needs patient population and says 25
percent of its patients don't pay for
their care it says the five million
dollars in annual rent it owes medical
properties trust represents only 3
percent of the annual operating budget
and was absolutely not a factor in the
decision to close the hospital but in a
recording obtained by CBS News the CEO
of the hospital did raise the issue of
rent What does Steward Trend do they're
trying to get out of these obligations I
didn't know you could like rent out a
hospital I was under the impression that
we owned the building it's just
infuriating councilwoman rosha Garcia
told us when it comes to figuring out
the financial reasons for Texas business
closure she's in the dark where's the
transparency here
it's there is no transparency you can't
see like you know what the income is
what the expenses were
nothing nothing so as a regulator I
could stop it here Rhode Island attorney
general Peter narona told us last fall
authorities around the country need more
tools to protect hospitals his state
passed an unusual law giving him the
power to scrutinize Hospital
transactions and block a potential real
estate sale laws on the books like that
allow us to intervene to make sure that
the Health Care system is going to be
one of quality that's affordable and
accessible without those laws he told us
it can be hard to follow the money one
thing is clear for executives at Medical
properties trust buying Hospital real
estate has been lucrative hello I'm Ed
Al dag with medical properties trust
according to the company's SEC filings
from 2017 to 2021 CEO Edward aldags
salary bonuses and stock awards amounted
to a total of about 70 million dollars
it felt like it became less about people
and more about profits
Edward aldag declined an interview in a
statement medical properties trust said
it has no involvement in operational
decisions at the facilities it owns and
denied its lease agreements have caused
any of them to cut services or fail
Steward Healthcare said it has invested
close to two billion dollars in its 39
hospitals including 100 million in Texas
Vista Stewart says without its
commitment Texas Vista would have closed
years ago Jessica Carrasco told us she's
lost the place where her grandparents
sought care and where everyone knew her
daughter's name it's very emotional so
so what happens to the rent payments
when the hospital closes well we've been
told that the rent payments are still
being made remember Stewart is a big
company he's got dozens of dozens of
other hospitals other assets but you
know this is the point of transparency
we can't look behind the curtain here
and say well what does the balance sheet
look like what money is going where so
we're left wondering I'm not sure
exactly what's going on financially I
know you've done a couple of
jaw-dropping stories on this topic are
you seeing a theme Here John yeah for me
the the two themes are number one what
happens when private Equity brushes up
against Health Equity
and the second is this issue of
transparency right we we just don't know
what's going on and I go back to what uh
attorney general uh narona in Rhode
Island said to us his advice for
everybody watching this around the
country is he has in Rhode Island the
power to when there's a transaction
involving a hospital to open up the
books and to look a thing and to examine
it and he thinks that people around the
country need that same tool for sure so
that it's just more visible shine light
on the process and then say you know
okay what's going on is it okay yeah
yeah a hospital may be a private company
but it's serving a public and that
Public's health is on the line Dr John
LaPook thank you very much thank you
really eye-opening